Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
A chi non piacerebbe
avere un robot in casa,
che parla e magari fa le pulizie?
A voi piacerebbe?
Penso a tanti
Magari come questo?
Alzate le mani, per favore.
Se vi piace.
A chi gli piace?
Non ne vedo nemmeno una.
Qualcuno starà pensando
che magari è un po' troppo realistico.
Allora uno un po'
meno realistico, come questo?
Alzate la mano, per favore.
Nemmeno una!
Questo, ad esempio,
ha dei tratti umani,
ma che sono semplificati.
Vediamone un altro.
Questo?
Sì, alzate la mano:
io vedo tante mani alzate.
Va bene.
Ecco: ma cos'è che ci fa avere paura
di quelli che alla fine sono oggetti?
C'è una teoria al riguardo, si chiama -
in realtà è un'ipotesi,
l'ipotesi dell' "Uncanny Valley",
in italiano "Valle perturbante".
Se poniamo: sull'asse delle ascisse
la verosimiglianza con l'essere umano;
sull'asse delle ordinate
la familiarità che proviamo,
l'ipotesi dice che abbiamo
una curva che ha questa forma.
Ossia un robot, dall'essere
una scatola di metallo,
man mano che ha fattezze sempre più umane,
noi proviamo più familiarità,
e empatia verso di esso,
fino a un certo punto in cui,
nella curva, troviamo la valle.
In fondo a questa valle,
troviamo magari dei capolavori di ricerca
come quelli che vi ho mostrato;
che però, essendo simili all'essere umano,
essendo quasi essere umano,
quel "quasi" è sinonimo
di qualcosa che non quadra.
E cos'è che non quadra,
nel fondo della valle?
Possono essere dimensioni distorte,
come nel caso di CB2,
un robot bambino di uno o due anni;
o parti meccaniche miste
a parti che sembrano organiche;
oppure dettagli che non corrispondono
alle nostre aspettative,
o meglio alle aspettative
del nostro cervello.
Tutte queste cose, e l'ambiguità
in sé della somiglianza,
possono rendere un robot inquietante.
Ma c'è di più.
C'è un motivo ancora più profondo,
che è radicato nel nostro passato.
Sicuramente, tutti voi
conoscerete film di fantascienza.
Un caso famoso è quello di Terminator.
In molti di questi, una storia comune
è sempre quella dei robot
che a un certo punto si ribellano
e cercano di sterminare l'umanità.
Tipico.
Però questa non è
una prerogativa dei robot,
perchè già esisteva una storia precedente
che conosciamo bene, quella di Pinocchio,
un umano artificiale
che a un certo punto va fuori controllo.
E prima ancora, dall'inizio dell'800,
la storia di Frankenstein,
in cui la creatura - un'altra volta,
una creatura artificiale,
va fuori controllo,
e per questo viene chiamato
"complesso di Frankenstein".
Bene, ad esempio questo complesso
non esiste in Giappone.
In Giappone i robot sono visti, spesso,
come eroi che salvano l'umanità
e hanno sentimenti, un'anima.
E questa che vedete
è una statua alta 20 metri
che è presente in una piazza a Tokio.
Ma allora, noi, questa paura
da dove l'abbiamo presa?
La nostra cultura deriva
dall'antica Grecia.
E nella mitologia greca,
c'erano tante storie
riguardo all'automazione,
come quella del Pigmalione,
in cui egli scolpì,
un uomo che scolpì
una statua di una donna,
e s'innamorò di essa.
Però non c'era niente di negativo
in questa storia,
e in tutte queste storie di automazione.
Quindi non abbiamo preso questa paura,
evidentemente, dalla cultura greca.
Per paragone, vediamo anche in Cina:
per millenni hanno inventato loro
gli spettacoli di ombre cinesi,
in cui queste marionette prendevano vita
grazie ai movimenti di fili alle giunture.
Bene, allora non lo sappiamo con certezza,
ma probabilmente la prima storia
di questo genere, di questa paura,
è la storia del Golem,
fin dall'età medievale, poi nel 1600,
che è una storia di eredità ebraica.
Questa storia, il Golem,
è una creatura fatta di argilla,
creata da un rabbino,
è una creatura che non poteva
né parlare né pensare.
Andò fuori controllo,
e dovette essere distrutta.
E questo è un esempio di "hybris",
cioè della superbia,
in questo caso, dell'uomo
nel voler creare qualcosa
di vivo e artificiale.
Quindi, vedendo complessivamente
Occidente e Oriente,
hanno radici molto lontane fra di loro,
ma da ambo le parti
abbiamo storie di umani artificiali.
E nel presente, però, abbiamo:
da una parte il complesso di Frankenstein;
dall'altra parte un'immagine positiva.
Cosa è successo, nel mezzo,
che ha portato a questa diversione?
Una possibile spiegazione
è l'influenza delle religioni,
perché nelle religioni monoteistiche
c'è una distinzione netta
tra il naturale e l'artificiale,
quello che è creato da Dio,
e quello che non è stato creato da Dio,
ma è stato creato dall'uomo.
Nelle religioni orientali,
ispirate al confucianesimo,
influenzate dal confucianesimo,
ogni oggetto ha un'anima.
Torniamo al presente.
Io ho lavorato e studiato
tanti anni a Tokyo.
Questo è il robot con cui ho lavorato:
un umanoide molto avanzato.
Che però, a volte, mi ricordava qualcosa.
(Risate)
Bene, disegnato da ingegneri.
Forse è proprio questo il punto.
Perché piuttosto
che disegnare questi robot
soltanto in base alla loro funzionalità,
forse dovremmo ispirarci al design,
proprio al campo del design.
Come fa la Apple, ad esempio,
che è un'azienda
che ha saputo trarre vantaggio
dall'unione tra tecnologia e design.
Loro si sono avvalsi
di un concetto di design
chiamato "scheumorfismo" .
La parola "scheumorfismo"
deriva dal greco,
significa da "skeuos", contenitore,
e "morphé" , che vuol dire forma.
Significa creare un nuovo oggetto
con l'apparenza, con l'aspetto
di un oggetto che esiste già,
con cui l'utente è già familiare.
E applicato a un'applicazione,
come la libreria,
alla sinistra vedete come era disegnata
nelle prime versioni dell'iOS,
cioè con l'aspetto
di uno scaffale di legno.
Successivamente,
quando hanno pensato, evidentemente,
che gli utenti ormai si erano abituati,
sono passati a un'interfaccia flat.
Ma disegnare robot in base
a questo concetto che cosa comporta?
Perché i robot sono, possibilmente,
l'oggetto tecnologico
più complesso che esista,
perché sono lo specchio dell'uomo.
Allora, se sono lo specchio dell'uomo,
evidentemente, come abbiamo visto
in precedenza, parlando di cultura,
dobbiamo considerare
la nostra cultura, il nostro passato,
nel modo in cui li disegniamo.
Se ci pensate, le automobili
sono personalizzate
per i diversi mercati del mondo,
così come tanti altri oggetti in vendita.
Allora, a maggior ragione
i robot devono essere personalizzati.
E non possiamo prescindere, nella cultura,
dal considerare anche
la religione che l'ha improntata.
Questa foto l'ho scattata
all'Isola di Pasqua,
che fa vedere, proprio emblematicamente,
un Mohai con una croce,
quindi il pagano con il sacro.
Vediamo un esempio: il Dharma,
questo qui a destra,
è un talismano di buona sorte,
protezione, proveniente dal buddhismo.
È molto comune, quindi, nella cultura
sia in Giappone che in Cina.
E aiuta, per chi ci crede,
a realizzare i propri desideri,
che nella foto stanno tutti scritti
nei bigliettini a sinistra.
Il Dharma, in generale,
è un oggetto di piccole dimensioni
che molti giapponesi tengono in casa.
Allora, prendendo questo come modello,
come ispirazione tramite scheumorfismo,
abbiamo realizzato
un piccolo robot sociale,
per la compagnia degli anziani,
che assume l'identità del Dharma.
E questo io l'ho portato in un ospizio,
in diversi ospizi, in Giappone,
o almeno un prototipo di questo.
E gli anziani, come tutti sapete,
non sono propriamente
amanti delle nuove tecnologie,
ne sono abbastanza intimoriti.
Quelli giapponesi non fanno eccezione.
Però, questo Dharma parlante
non li ha intimoriti,
perché è qualcosa che conoscono già,
è presente nel loro passato.
Quindi abbiamo,
probabilmente con successo,
utilizzato la religione
all'interno del design di tecnologia.
Ma religione e tecnologia
non sono campi uno all'opposto dell'altro,
non sono uno contro l'altro?
In realtà, no.
La religione non è per definizione
contro la tecnologia,
perché anche la religione si è evoluta
passando dalla tradizione orale
alla tradizione scritta,
alla stampa, ai mass media.
E presto potrà trarre beneficio
da nuove tecnologie
come l'intelligenza artificiale
per facilitarne la diffusione.
E la robotica anch'essa ha
delle origini molto antiche
che si intersecano
con quelle delle religioni.
Erone di Alessandria,
nell'età ellenistica,
disegnò diversi "automata":
così venivano chiamati dei marchingegni
che eseguivano dei movimenti.
E questi venivano molto spesso
messi dentro templi,
come l'altare a Dioniso, che lui disegnò.
E in epoche successive,
il maggior sforzo per queste opere,
di questi automata, indovinate chi era?
La Chiesa cattolica,
alla ricerca di mezzi
per impressionare i fedeli.
Quello che vedete nel mezzo
è il monaco meccanico
commissionato come opera votiva
da Filippo II di Spagna nel 1560.
E da altre parti del mondo,
ad esempio in India,
da millenni si usano marionette
durante le festività indù.
E in Giappone, in epoche successive,
con l'invenzione dei primi automata,
queste, chiamate "bambole Kara Kuri",
venivano poste anche
all'interno dei templi.
In generale,
per rappresentare il tema religioso,
si fa uso della bellezza.
Si fa uso dell'arte, dell'arte sacra;
ad esempio, la sezione aurea
è un concetto che è molto utilizzato
e si può trovare frequentemente
in molte opere rinascimentali, ad esempio,
di una certa importanza religiosa.
E come dice il Corano,
"Dio è bello e ama la bellezza",
Perché l'arte sacra non è soltanto un'arte
che ha per tema qualcosa di sacro.
Ma è intrinsecamente sacra,
perché tramite la bellezza
trasmette il concetto di divino.
Quindi, allora, forse abbiamo la chiave:
usiamo lo scheumorfismo
ispirandoci all'arte sacra,
per portare qualcosa di familiare.
E in Italia siamo pieni di arte sacra,
nei luoghi più impensabili.
Io un tempo non ci facevo caso,
vivendo a Livorno;
ma abituandomi ad altri paesaggi urbani,
adesso che torno mi saltano
all'occhio molti dettagli,
tra cui, ad esempio,
un elemento decorativo molto diffuso:
sono dei santi in una nicchia,
come potete vedere in queste foto,
le ho scattate anche a Livorno.
Questi santini non hanno soltanto
una funzione decorativa,
perché sono proprio un oggetto
di conforto per un credente,
perché fanno da intermediario con Dio
e perché contengono, incorporano simboli.
Bene.
Basandoci su questa ispirazione,
vi presento il primo robot cattolico
dai tempi di Filippo Secondo di Spagna.
O forse sarebbe meglio chiamarlo
un "Santo interattivo",
perché altro non è
che un'opera di arte sacra
con delle funzionalità innovative.
E vista l'occasione, lo ho anche portato.
Con molta delicatezza, perché è sacro.
Questo è stato disegnato tenendo conto
dei canoni di bellezza,
ispirandosi all'architettura neoclassica.
E contiene delle dimensioni
di sezione aurea.
E si accende semplicemente
ponendo una candela elettronica
e toccandogli le mani.
Non ha altre interfacce
come schermi, telecomandi, bottoni,
e diavolerie elettroniche di sorta.
Le componenti elettroniche,
come i motori, il microfono, gli speaker,
sono tutti contenuti,
sono mascherati dall'apparenza,
quindi sono nascosti dentro:
dentro il corpo del santo,
e dentro la nicchia.
E in quanto ai contenuti,
questo contiene storie
di vite dei santi, sermoni, preghiere;
può contenere un database
di tutte queste cose
che lo rendono un plausibile
compagno per la preghiera
per tante persone anziane,
o sole, che ne hanno bisogno.
E io l'ho portato
in un ospizio in Germania.
Questa è una foto in cui stanno pregando,
insieme, il Padre Nostro.
Quindi, per concludere,
i robot sono oggetti complessi,
come è complesso l'uomo.
Però i robot sono all'orizzonte.
E dobbiamo decidere ora come crearli,
per fare in modo che siano
socialmente accettabili.
E perché siano accettabili
serve che siano familiari;
perché siano familiari, dobbiamo ispirarci
alla nostra cultura e al nostro passato.
E se esaminiamo la cultura,
dobbiamo anche considerare la religione.
E se tocchiamo la religione,
dobbiamo anche riesaminare,
ristudiarci, i canoni di bellezza.
E finisco con un invito:
in Italia siamo stati
il centro dell'Umanesimo,
quindi il centro dello studio dell'uomo.
E non solo.
Siamo i maestri dell'arte nel mondo.
E inoltre, abbiamo istituti
all'avanguardia
nella ricerca in robotica
e nuove tecnologie.
Allora con questi tre elementi, dico io:
creiamoli noi italiani
questi robot accettabili,
e soprattutto belli,
che rispecchino il nostro passato.
Grazie.
(Applausi)